un bébé opéré dans le ventre de sa maman
pour la première fois des cellules
foetales ont été injectés un fétu
justement l'intervention s'est déroulée
à lyon dans le service du professeur
touraine à l'hôpital edouard herriot ça
s'est passé en juin 88 2 mois avant la
naissance du bébé
aujourd'hui david est toujours à l'abri
des microbes il vit dans une bulle
stérile
marie françoise riou l'opération
réalisée par l'équipe du professeur
touraine s'est déroulée sous le contrôle
d'un écran d'échographie celle
échographistes qui a constamment guidé
la main du chirurgien celui ci a injecté
des cellules aux bébés par la voie du
cordon ombilical
ces tissus avait été auparavant
prélevées sur des cadavres de foetus âgé
de quelques semaines
cette technique est déjà utilisée sur
des enfants à la naissance pour la
première fois on la pratique in utero
c'est un grand espoir pour la centaine
d'enfants qui chaque année en france
seraient susceptibles d'être opéré de
cette manière mais au risque de se
heurter une nouvelle fois à des
problèmes éthiques sur une soirée
poétique
au jour d'aujourd'hui ce serait de
priver des enfants qui ont maintenant
une chance de guérison de cette
possibilité
il ne serait pas éthique ne pas faire de
grève dit fut fait tôt
la réflexion a été conduite elle a
abouti à une recommandation positive il
faut continuer cegla tissu fait tôt et
en particulier pour les enfants qui
n'ont pas d'autre chance de guérison qui
seraient condamnés que maintenant on
peut guérir par une greffe après
naissance
et puis même plus récemment par une
greffe avant la naissance
il faut pouvoir réaliser ses actifs et
aux et il faut que nous obtenions le
nombre de cellules qui est nécessaire
pour traiter tous les enfants de france
qui en ont besoin